Mit diesem plan könnte man tatsächlich eines der größten probleme unserer zeit lösen wenn er denn klappt die rede ist vom
trinkwassermangel in vielen regionen dieser erde ein unternehmer aus den vereinigten arabischen emiraten hat jetzt einen kühnen plan
eisberge aus der antarktis sollen tausende von kilometern transportiert werden um den wasserarmen regionen als frisches trinkwasser
aufbereitet zu werden j wie genau das funktionieren soll und wie erfolgsversprechend das projekt tatsächlich ist jetzt bei klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich neue science videos abonniert den kanal gerne herzlich willkommen
Auch wenn die erde zu rund 70 prozent vom wasser bedeckt ist nur ein prozent der wasservorräte
weltweit ist direkt als trinkwasser verfügbar und das ist ein riesiges problem laut weltgesundheitsorganisation
who und unicef haben mehr als 800 millionen menschen weltweit keinen zugang zu sauberem wasser
2,3 milliarden das sind fast dreimal so viele menschen haben nicht die möglichkeit sanitäre anlagen wie toiletten zu benutzen
wassermangel betrifft derzeit vor allem noch die ärmsten auf dieser welt doch schon bald werden auch die wasservorräte
bedroht sein wo sie derzeit noch im überfluss vorhanden sind und klar ist ohne
wasser gibt es kein leben keine industrie und keine landwirtschaft mit diesem versorgungsproblem hat sich auch der arabische
unternehmer abdullah als chemie beschäftigt er hat eine idee
aufgegriffen die schon seit den 70er jahren immer wieder mal diskutiert wird sein plan einen eisberg von der antarktis
bis nach dubai zu befördern um das eis dort als trinkwasser nutzen zu können dazu als
wenn wir mit diesem projekt erfolgreich sind könnte es eines der größten probleme der welt lösen
eine pilotstudie ist für november geplant
satellitenbilder sollen analysiert werden um im südlichen ozean nach einem geeigneten eisberg zu suchen dieser könnte dann mithilfe von ketten
und netzen und einer flotte anboten nach australien oder
südafrika geschleppt werden das gewicht der eisberge auf die es als chemie abgesehen hat wird auf etwa
100 millionen tonnen geschätzt es handelt sich also um richtige mammut berge viel zu groß
als dass sie von schiffen allein gezogen werden könnten so soll laut plan nach günstigen
meeresströmungen ausschau gehalten werden um die reise zu beschleunigen das arabische unternehmen schätzt dass eisberge solcher dimension mit einer
geschwindigkeit von etwa zweieinhalb
kilometern pro stunde bewegt werden könnten also sehr sehr langsam eine reise in die vereinigten arabischen
emirate könnte so bis zu elf monate dauern am ziel angekommen sollte eisberg dann nach und nach in kleinere teile
zerkleinert werden tankschiffe könnten das eis zum ufer bringen hier müsste das wasser dann gereinigt werden und könnte somit an wasser
gesellschaften oder die jeweilige regierung verkauft werden doch es gibt noch einige herausforderungen
die bewältigt werden müssen eine große menge des eisberges würde wohl während des transportes schmelzen oder sogar
auseinanderfallen dazu der gletscherexperte nick holschuh von der universität washington
der transport von eis über diese entfernung wird eine große herausforderung sein man muss nicht nur mit
verlusten durch direktes schmelzen rechnen auch das mechanische aufbrechen des eisbergs muss verhindert werden dass warme meereswasser
wärmere luft und belastung durch das abschleppen werden die stabilität des eisbergs beeinflussen als
selbst zeigt sich davon unbeeindruckt er geht davon aus dass nur 30 prozent des eisberges auf der reise von der antarktis in die arabischen emirate
schmelzen werden alle kosten und mühen seines wert wenn man damit den trinkwasserbedarf zahlreicher menschen decken könnte konkret geht er von
100 millionen bis 200 millionen kubikmeter süßwasser aus die in einem eisberg
eingeschlossen sind diese könnten ausreichen um eine million menschen für fünf jahre
mit trinkwasser zu versorgen so als chemie zudem sei auch nicht mit negativen folgen für die umwelt zu rechnen schließlich würden lediglich diejenigen
eisbergen wegtransportiert die bereits vom eisschild der antarktis
abgebrochen sein die kosten des projektes werden auf 60 millionen dollar geschätzt das wort von privaten investoren übernommen werden
lautes arabische unternehmers könnte der plan bereits im kommenden frühjahr in die tat umgesetzt werden
langfristig will als dann zahlreiche
eisberge in region liefern die unter wassermangel
dazu der unternehmer die ganze welt braucht wasser aber zuerst würden wir länder wie indien südafrika und
saudi arabien betrachten sagt er seine idee hat jetzt bereits nachahmer gefunden ein team aus südafrika norwegen und frankreich
plant ebenfalls eine solche mission konkret soll hier kapstadt mit einem eisberg aus der antarktis beliefert werden dazu der südafrikanische schifffahrts experte
nicholas lohnt die leute denken immer noch die idee sei verrückt aber in letzter zeit wird diese lösung immer öfter diskutiert
und es setzt langsam ein umdenken ein
kapstadt hat in diesem jahr extrem unter wassermenge mangel leiden müssen
das waschen von autos das blumen gießen oder das pool befüllen wurde von der regierung strengstens verboten
würde seinen eisberg projekt teurer
entsalzungsanlagen überflüssig machen und somit keine mehrkosten
für kapstadt bedeuten das einzige was noch fehle sei das gros der stadt denn investoren
für das projekt seien bereits gefunden so und jetzt könnt ihr die sieger bei den community award
2018 des wissenschafts video welches fast vorwärts 1 mitbestimmen ich war ja als jurymitglied dabei und kann nur sagen
hammer videos hier steht wie es geht und hier drunter ist die playlist mit allen finalisten
abgestimmt wird einfach mit einem like oder einem kommentar ich drücke allen teilnehmerinnen die daumen bis dann
bleibt dran